we have been on this story from the
beginning and it has now been confirmed
exclusively by Newsweek based on a
classified report that they've obtained
that yes Russian President Vladimir
Putin has received treatment for cancer
and has suffered an assassination
attempt which we will talk about as well
now if you've been watching our show
listening to the podcast this General
story would not be new to you there are
many media Outlets that have not even
talked about this possibility but our
audience many of you will remember this
it seemed that something was wrong back
on April 25th when we reported in a
segment called visibly bloated Putin
grip's table for support in new video
that something seemed very wrong and
that was after earlier speculation from
some doctors in our audience that
something seemed just not quite right
with Vladimir Putin now then in may we
reported on the belief that Putin had
cancer it was more specifically being
discussed at that point in time and
three days after we did that video
Ukraine's head of intelligence Major
General Carrillo budanov told UK's Sky
News that Putin was in quote a very bad
psychological and physical condition and
he is very sick but okay I mean that's
Ukraine's head of intelligence it may be
accurate but Ukraine may also have
reasons to push that narrative
um and the context here is very
important because the question we've
been asking is why is Putin acting so
seemingly belligerently this invasion of
Ukraine seems like a bad idea it's now
been going on even longer and it's not
clear that it's one that necessarily
Russia is going to be able to quote win
at least not decisively at least not
without suffering massive losses on
which we've already reported so one of
the theory and then I actually I
shouldn't say Theory even though I mean
Theory colloquially
one of the hypotheses or speculations
was
if Putin were ill either as a result of
he feels like he has nothing to lose or
as a side effect of medication all
speculative maybe he's not thinking
clearly and he's acting belligerently
and he wants to go out in some kind of
Blazing Glory trying to return Russia to
the USSR era you know again it was all
speculative but the question was could
something medical maybe relate to why
he's behaving in this way and the answer
now appears to be well at least maybe
because it now has apparently been
confirmed that Putin was treated for
cancer and we're going to talk about
what specifically is being reported a
classified U.S report
obtained by Newsweek says that Vladimir
Putin has re-emerged after undergoing
treatment for cancer in April for what
they are describing as quite Advanced
cancer according to three U.S
intelligence leaders from this
classified report the report also
confirms that there was an assassination
attempt on Putin's life in March now
we've seen these videos of when Putin
meets with people he's he sits very far
from them these cartoonishly long tables
and that applies to other people that
work for him within Russia but also even
sometimes when he meets with foreign
leaders and there were two speculations
there one speculation is he's worried
about an assassination attempt including
maybe that the people even that work for
him might turn on him and try to kill
him
now it has learned that he did there was
an assassination attempt in March
secondly the speculation was well maybe
he's just like really afraid of coven
maybe because he's immunocompromised as
a result of possible treatment that he's
receiving many cancer treatments and
other treatments can suppress your
immune system and that would be another
potential explanation this report
doesn't clarify whether it's one the
other or both because both things appear
to have uh to appear to be true
three intelligence officials from the
office of the dni a retired Air Force
senior officer and an official from the
defense intelligence agency say it's
difficult to know exactly what's going
on but that number one the main points
of Putin is afraid of assassination
attempts and Putin did undergo treatment
for cancer those two points are being
reported as being true according to this
classified report the three intelligence
officials also say that this makes the
prospect of nuclear war less likely
which has been a concern for a while
they don't elaborate as to why and I'm
not actually sure why they believe this
report about Putin's cancer treatment
makes nuclear war less likely maybe
we'll get more information about that
um also interesting the Russian foreign
minister Sergey lavrov a major
propagandist he was asked about this
notion of Putin being sick in an
interview last weekend on French
television and he straight up denied it
he said quote I don't think that a sane
person can suspect any signs of an
illness or ailment in this man and if
Sergey lavrov is so vehemently denying
something
it it genuinely might point to it being
true because that the guy is just a
constant and total liar so the bottom
line here according to the defense
intelligence agency official is Putin is
definitely sick but whether he is close
to death is mere speculation we just
have no idea natural question if someone
has undergone cancer treatment well what
type of cancer unclear the speculation
over the last two months has been
prostate cancer
thyroid cancer but it is merely
speculation at this point there have
also been speculations about Parkinson's
or something parkinsonian you could have
cancer in Parkinson's there are now with
the cancer piece more in focus
there's also speculation that the
parkinsonian appearance may have been a
result of maybe medication or treatment
but again there are lots of speculative
elements the one that seems to now be
out of the realm of speculation and into
the line of fact based on the classified
report is yes cancer of some kind and
treatment in April
um will we ever know the full truth
maybe I don't know but a very very
interesting report and it seems that
what was believed early on
indeed appears to be at least to some
degree now confirmed
we've talked often about the
Mediterranean diet the Mediterranean
diet one element is olive oil and many
olive oils are adulterated with fillers
other types of oils are made with oils
that are old or low quality brightland
is where you get the good stuff
brightland is a california-based company
offering authentic fresh olive oils and
vinegars made from local harvests never
over processed no fillers or artificial
preservatives because brightland only
works with small california-based
family-run farms that don't use harmful
chemicals they pay all workers a living
wage every bottle has a label with the
harvest date olives are harvested early
in the season pressed within 90 minutes
of harvest for the highest quality oil
possible brightland sells an olive oil
set called The Duo which I've been using
at home it's unbeatable one is called
awake it's a robust or oil for Breads
and soups the other is called alive it's
smoother great for veggies and salads
brightland ships to you in recyclable
bottles that protect against UV light
and in sustainable packaging when you go
to
brightland.co Pacman you'll get 10 off
the duo the link is down below